we live in a whorehouse he was born in
1941 in Albuquerque in New Mexico and in
1967 he received his PhD from MIT
Cambridge Massachusetts USA and at that
point he moved to Yale University as an
assistant professor and then you climbed
in the ranks and you've been at Yale
University
ever since if I understand correctly and
that's 51 years a pretty impressive
tenure record and I don't know if you're
a broken record but I hope you will
break the record whatever it is William
Nordhaus has focused on the one part of
race or resources I focus on nature a
crucial resource for us naturally and
the point here is that human activity
economic activity effects our resources
effects um through climate change in
particular so he built up the area that
we refer to as integrated assessment of
the interaction between the economy and
the climate so ladies and gentlemen
please welcome Professor William Norris
[Applause]
in the interest of modern technology I
will use an iPhone to time myself
thank you very much the the 2018 award
and economic science recognizes the
significance of technological change in
climate change these two fields are
closely related because both grapple
with externalities or spill overs
associated with economic growth
they both examine what are known as
market failures in other words they deal
with the inability of unfettered or
unregulated markets to ensure that
economic growth effectively satisfies
human needs while protecting ourselves
in our environment my lecture will focus
on part of that which is climate change
and the challenges nations face in
devising policies to slow climate change
now why I'm here today and talking today
and on the podium today I'm just one
person representing what I think of as
an invisible college of people around
the world and over time not just in
economics but in many disciplines
I'll talk about that in a minute dealing
with this broad set of problems having
to do not just with climate change but
with the interaction of the economy with
the natural world and our interactions
with that I'm here thanks to my parents
to my wife Barbara who's been my
companion for my entire adult life
my children who are with me my
grandchildren who are with me my
teachers who have been such inspiration
and a substantial number of whom have
been on the equivalent of this stage
over the years my colleagues many of
whom are here my students some of whom
are here and my critics I think some of
whom are here and I want I want to say a
special word of thanks to my critics
because those are the people you learn
from the most and finally thanks for the
institution's I I want to emphasize
something that's particularly important
to me and I think actually although we
don't always recognize that the
institutions that have supported us our
schools our families but there's a mini
institution our schools our universities
our national academies of Sweden in the
United States other places and these are
the places that mean we live in a
magnificent Hall like this so we are in
a magnificent Hall like this we live in
prosperous democracies rather than in
caves and dying at an early age and
without these I would be a hot carrier
in Albuquerque or something the
equivalent of that so my thanks to all
of those now coming back to the talk
today we have a climate problem because
markets fail and fail badly in the
energy sector they fail because one of
the byproducts of the use of energy in
particular fossil fuels is unpriced and
therefore underpriced markets put a zero
price on this by-product this unintended
by-product this externality whereas the
true social cost of carbon dioxide and
as in the particular case is
as we've learned hi just how high how to
put a price on carbon and how to deal
with this is the subject of an extensive
body of research and that's also the
subject of this talk today economics has
developed a toolbox and analytical
toolbox to deal with externalities as I
said these externalities are the
unintended by pilot products or spill
overs of economic growth they they occur
outside the market they're not captured
in market prices and global warming is
the closest of all environmental
externalities and I have a very terrible
picture here of this is the colossus of
Goya but I use this because many of you
know this it's in the Prado but I think
of I think of climate change as a menace
to our planet to our future it's
particularly pernicious because it
involves so many activities of daily
life it affects the entire planet it
does so for decades and even centuries
and it's challenging most of all because
none of us acting alone as ethical
individuals can do anything about it to
slow the change and so like the people
huddling there some of us anyway are
very frightened by the prospect so let's
let's turn from this this art this art
to another art which is economics and to
the sign the sciences of climate change
and so maybe we'll turn there so climate
climate change involves many many
sectors or disciplines such as
atmospheric chemistry geophysics
Glaciology ecology economics political
science
game theory international law just to
mention some of the most significant
ones and because these climate change
it's so interconnected the parts are so
interconnected we need integrated what
was mentioned earlier is integrated
assessment or integrated assessment
modeling to deal with this problem in a
you know rigorous way and there are
there are things I'll talk about them in
a minute called integrated assessment
models they integrate now knowledge from
multiple disciplines into a single
framework or single model and these
these the models are based on
fundamental scientific theories they're
increasingly computerized they are
computerized we have analysis as well
but they're the models themselves are
generally computerized models of various
levels of complexity my own work on
integrated assessment models began in a
very simple model of first energy and
then later on including climate and it
began in 1974 when I was at the
International Institute in Vienna and
then I I think of myself as stumbling
along for almost two decades trying
different approaches the first one
wasn't right the second wasn't right the
third one wasn't ride they didn't they
couldn't capture the things partly it
was I didn't know the analysis partly it
was some of these areas weren't
developed empirically or analytically
until in 1992 I finally landed on like
land on the moon I landed on that what's
known as the dice model which is just
the name of a model but I think it
captures it's the name of a model but
also captures some of the riskiness that
that is involved and I'll talk I'll talk
about a little bit later today the
current version of that which is updated
to roughly two today which has the same
basic analytical structure as the
earlier model but has evolved both in
terms of parameters in terms of some of
the details of the sector's but the
structure is basically the same as it
was in 1992 and the structure of the
model is shown in the figure here I'll
just describe it briefly you have
economic growth leading to emissions on
the upper left and that's from our
driving or heating or cooking our
airplane dharia travel this leads to
rising co2 concentrations and other
forces leading to climate change and
climate change is not just temperature
but it's precipitation and sea level
rise and many other processes and then
that to the next arrow it has impacts
Tarot it has impacts of ecological
impacts economic impacts lower corn
yields coastal flooding ocean
acidification which is actually the
other carbon dioxide problem which I
won't talk about very much but it's bad
for
crustaceans and then the next is so the
next link is climate clay and change
policies to reduce emissions and these
would be through different mechanisms
such as cap-and-trade which you know
here in Europe but carbon taxes which
you know in Sweden regulations which are
all countries know and then that then
through the policies leads back up to
affecting emissions reducing emissions
and then affecting more you know a
greater or lesser degree climate you can
AMA growth itself and I put those arrows
there to see in the end the first to
error is that ones we know about and
actually exist the other two we don't
actually all lives don't actually exist
in all cases so this is the lot this is
the circular flow that is part of the
modeling that we're talking about today
so I want to say a word see what we're
doing here
I was saying a word about mathematics
for just a little bit of mathematics as
a language particularly for people for
young people and students and who are
thinking about what they're going to
study my first teacher and and mentor
and co-author Paul Samuelson was also
the first American Merrick
laureate in economics and he was
responsible for the introduction of
mathematics into economics and his view
was mathematics is necessary if we were
to understand and analyze complex
phenomena and it's something that point
is now part of my brain it's it's
actually built in just as much as the
English language is it's it's is part of
my brain and it's an interesting the
great American physicist John Willard
Gibbs
in a Yale faculty meeting when there was
debate about foreign languages he stood
up and he said mathematics is language
and he sat down and and he's right the
language and that language is
increasingly part of our lives it's from
the design of the computers that are
running this the show here to our power
plants to the medical scans that save
our lives and I think mathematics is our
future that's all I mean I think we need
to study foreign languages we need to
study all kinds of things poetry art but
mathematics is is key to so many areas
of our future the math the language of
mathematics is also central to our
modeling of climate change economics
I'll just show you a little picture here
I thought I'd show you the mathematics
of the model and here it is that's all
that's all it is it's a maximization
constrained maximization problem it's
kind of simple so there's a lot of
vectors here and times and integrals and
so on and it'll be discretized for the
actual computerized model but any of you
who know the modeling and know
mathematical economics will say oh yeah
that's just that's a simple old growth
model that we know and love for so many
years ago
and those of you who know mathematics
will say well that's kind of interesting
and those of you don't just view it as a
it's just it's a counterpoint of goya
it's just a picture here okay maybe not
so frightening I don't know maybe more
frightening but don't don't be
frightened don't be frightened so
economists have focused on the strata so
let me just turn out of to a little bit
of the actual results so economists have
focused on the economists and others
have focused on strategies to slow
climate change and they're they're
basically three but
strategies abatement or reduction of
emissions is the one I'll focus on the
second one is removing carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere which would be
running wonderful but actually you could
grow trees to do that for example but
but well I won't say but and then
there's management of Soto solar
radiation through say putting dust in
the stratosphere abatement the first one
I mentioned is the only realistic and
safe option at present others may come
along but at present it's all that we
have so I'm gonna concentrate there but
after to say well realistic it's also
expensive particularly in if we are
ambitious and just to give an example a
common goal of the international
negotiations and policies is to limit
temperature to two degrees C above
pre-industrial levels and estimates are
that that would might cost about four
percent of our income over the next next
century or two this may be good for
nature but it's not actually all that
attractive to voters to reduce their
income that sharply so it shows some of
the trade-off
now that's abatement I'll say a word
about just a word about damages because
you know economics what we're going to
do is weigh the costs of reducing
emissions and slowing climate change or
limiting temperature on the one hand
with the reduction in damages on the
other so we have to you have to go out
and do the modeling you have to
determine what the damages are and you
might say well that's impact sound
easier because our babymoon do you need
the physics and the chemistry and all
that but actually damages and damages is
just economics and ecology but actually
damages are much much more difficult and
it's probably the most difficult task
and all of
processes that were on that last slide
because it's so far in the future the
things we don't understand very well
there
we don't have historical experience of
this so it's actually the probably the
most difficult so what I'll do is I'll
show you some illustrative results I
suppose these slides will be available
so that they will be available well
they'll be I guess they will be
available on the website so some of you
I know this goes by very fast but some
of you who want to look at them in
detail can go back and and find them but
I want to show you an example of the
results from the the dice model and this
I want to emphasize this is only one of
many models there there are people in
the room who do who do I won't point you
out but you know who you are who are
doing my other models and they're
they're wonderful models and people
around the world who are doing this the
only reason I present well the main
reason I presented is cuz I know it but
also it's a simple model has a virtue of
simplicity and comprehensiveness in the
sense that it does close that all the
boxes the links in that and another
model some do and some don't but I would
emphasize that these are very simplified
models and so for example the climate
sector two equations whereas if you go
to some of the large climate models
they'll have a million equations and so
these are very very these don't have the
resolution of the most the the most
comprehensive and up-to-date models so
he let me do pews me so I want to talk
about four sets of policies and I'll
just mention these briefly one is what a
business-as-usual which is basically no
policies or minimal policies a second
one is where you balance the costs and
the benefits a third is where you limit
temperatures over time to say one and a
half degrees which is the latest
objective or two degrees or two and a
half degrees and a third is is my
modification of that where you don't
limit it as an absolute cap but you're
limited over an average period the idea
being that actually makes more sense
because a lot of processes are function
of averages rather than just the
absolute level at point
time so those are the four that I'll
I'll show you some results from so one
is you you take these and I'll just one
other thing so you take this business as
usual what happened and then let's say
if you want to limit the temperature to
two degrees C which is in the third
bullet there how can you do that most
efficiently so it's not just any old way
but if that you've got costs of doing it
and you've got the systems and you want
to find how can I limit it to two
degrees in the way that's the most
caught the least costly and in the
economic sense so here's a here's a
picture that shows it's a little it's a
little crowded but I'll give you a quick
rundown so the top so on the this is
time from 0 to I've gone to 2150 just to
give it a little further depth and this
is then from 0 to 6 degrees C above
pre-industrial we're already at about
0.8 0.9 so and then this shows you
different paths doing this and the top
path is if we do nothing and you can see
that just keeps climbing and it's it's
pretty pretty substantial by the 20 120
150 and then there are other paths
there's one that have say economic
cost-benefit path where you balance
costs and benefits and then there's this
green one where you limit it to two
degrees C and then some of the other
ones are where you limited say two
degrees C with the 200-year averaging
two degrees C with a 100 year averaging
or one and a half degrees with a one
year 100 year averaging they all look
pretty much this so if you go out and
you they actually don't look very
different for quite a while and then
they begin to diverge after 2050 or so
but they'll have a very different path
but the main thing I'll show you is
actually if you take steps now to
implement these you have quite different
futures from very very high temperatures
on the one hand to relatively low for
the for the temperature limiting paths
the next slide I want to show you it
shows you the of the economics of this
so the the green
align the green bars show you and don't
worry too much about the the the units
here on the left they're their present
values but but they're just the bars or
what I want to emphasize on so you can
see the damages from doing nothing to
the optimal to the temperature limiting
and the damages obviously as you limit
temperature increase the damages are
going to go down from from left to right
and these are increasingly stringent
policies from left to right increasingly
ambitious policies and then so the
damages go down but then what are the
costs well they're not not much cost if
you don't do anything but as you become
increasingly ambitious the cross rise
and so you wanted but economics says
well how are you going to balance these
and if you if you were if your manukan
see that the extremes you have a lot of
damages and no cost at one extreme and a
lot of costs and very low damages or the
other and somehow in between you can
balance the two and what you want to
think of in economics or in more
generally is what's the best balance
between these two is that the optimal is
that a to degree is a averaging period
what different averaging period so you
want to find some balance between the
costs and the bending the damages no
economics yep
so economics points to one inconvenient
truth about climate change policy and
that is to be effective the policies
have to raise the price of carbon or co2
and by doing that correct the
externality of the marketplace and so
one of the I think one of the insights
of economics that I feel very strongly
about is if you're going to be effective
you have to raise the price because
putting a price on our activities is the
only way I mean we have to we have to
get billions of people in now and in the
future
millions of firms thousands of
governments to take steps if we're going
to move in the direction we want and the
only way that you're going to do that
effectively
is to increase the price of carbon and I
would say something about the history of
that because is I think it's an
interesting scientific story the idea on
carbon pricing flowed from the research
on what are known and technically is
dual variables in linear programming
from the pioneering work of kantorovich
and Koopmans for which then they won the
Nobel Prize in 1975 and it's if you do
this the optimization I showed you a
little earlier and you just Rock grind
and you just grind through it and you
look well we used to be computer
printouts we don't have those anymore
you would see the dual variables there
and I remember when I looked at I just
scratched my head I had no idea what
this dual variable on the carbon
constraint was and there were different
ones on different different different
reservoirs and then eventually I
realized and I'll quote when when I
first realized this is what I what I
wrote in 1977 and it's it's I haven't
gone much further than this because of
the externalities there are no market or
political mechanisms which ensure that
the appropriate level of control will be
chosen to implement the efficient path
implies that we are implicitly putting a
positive price on emissions of carbon
into the atmosphere quote carbon taxes
as a way of implementing the global
policy on a decentralized level so that
that that that was the first time it
really occurred to me that to think of
this in this way and so what basically I
it is evolved over time and I won't i
won't spend much more time on that i'll
just mention that this actually
disappeared for a long time and then
re-emerge about 20 years later in the
idea of the social cost of carbon which
is how much it costs to put a ton of
carbon in the atmosphere
and that's actually central now to
national policies it's central to the
design of carbon instead of climate
institutions as a setting a carbon price
or carbon tax so over the years nations
have negotiated many international
climate treaties the Framework
Convention the Kyoto Protocol the
Copenhagen Accord the Paris Accord how
are we doing you might ask how we doing
we we is the carbon price where it
should be or is it lower or higher the
answer that question is that the world
carbon price is nowhere near where
anyone thinks it ought to be it's maybe
1/10 of the most modest estimate of the
social cost of carbon the actual global
carbon price is essentially zero and I
I'm not going to go through the various
proofs of that but I want to talk about
what why that's a problem and what we
might do about it enough so as I think
about this the the read the problem here
is the that these treaties have been
ineffective in limiting carbon emissions
I'll just show actually I'll show you
one graph here which is the trend in
global emissions from 1970 to 2017
policies have been really ineffective in
dealing with climate change and the
reason is because of free riding and
freeriding is where you receive the
benefit of collective activity
collective action without paying the
cost without contributing and the case
of international climate policy what it
means is you ways you get the reduction
and damages due to people's efforts but
you don't have to do any costly steps at
home and so I'll just talk that's the
free rider problem in economics in
climate change
so in in research on this issue and
following much the brilliant studies of
the economics of treaties and game
theory I came to a solution that I
called a climate club and want to talk
about that in my last three minutes so
what is the idea of a climate club the
idea that nations can overcome the
syndrome of free riding in international
agreements if they adopt the the model
of a club and a club is an agreement
where you you know what clubs are we're
all in clubs of various kinds but
they're also international clubs is the
club of the EU to which which you
remember there's the club of NATO which
you're not a member but the Sweden is
not a member but is a beneficiary
there's the club of the World Trade
Organization of which we're all
beneficiaries and the idea for club here
is to change the way we think of
international agreements which are
essentially voluntary for climate to
make them ones where you you not only
benefit but you pay and for the example
that I'll suggest is an international
climate club to overcome free-writing is
the idea is that you would have club
played ooze through abatement but
members but non-members are penalized by
having tariffs on their imports into the
club region and so let's say you set a
target carbon price of $50 a ton
then nations would have their domestic
price through whatever mechanism they
would choose at $50 a ton but if you
weren't a participant then you would
have a penalty attack a penalty tariff
into the club region so the dues are
abatement and penalties are the tariff
and I'll just show you a very simple
example this is from my during my
presidential address to the American
Economic Association
and it's a very simple idea here the
bars from left to right are the tariff
rates of a club there are 15 regions in
this and the height of the bar is how
many participants there are as a
function of each tariff level and the
first tariff level is zero and that's
the basic structure where there's no
penalty to non participation and there
no participants but in this simple
example for a $50 tongue as the tariff
rates gets up to two three four five
percent you see more and more nations
participate and then it is high enough
all nations participate so we are
obviously a long way from the climate
club or analogous arrangements but I
think that I I think that we should we
should look at this as a kind of model
for future going forward so I think I'll
just wrap up here and I'll just make
four points to end up where we need to
go next
first we need to accept and understand
the gravity of climate change scientists
must continue their research and
citizens must reject politicians who
spread falchion tendentious reasoning
that's a very important step we must
establish policies that raise the price
of co2 and other greenhouse gas
emissions
we must act locally and nationally both
actions must also be coordinated on a
global level and it that's it and it's
clear that finally that we need rapid
technological change in the energy
sector for the transition so this
concludes my discussion of the economics
challenges posed by climate change and I
would emphasize the solution ultimately
lies in harnessing human ingenuity to
develop and deploy low-carbon
technologies
and with that thought with that thought
I'd like to turn to the extraordinary
insights on the economics of
technological change that have been
developed by my fellow laureate Paul
Romer so listen up
thank you
you
[Applause]